this video is brought to you by news
voice the news has broken almost all US
media is owned by just a handful of big
corporations also fake news is a huge
problem and just finding something
unbiased can be hard news voice is
revolutionizing the news landscape is an
app that gives you a personalized news
feed by aggregating major news sites as
well as international and independent
media giving some much-needed balance
each news story shows multiple sources
which are all tagged is there bias and
perspective the news affects almost
everything in our daily lives over here
and read shapes which persons we trust
what we eats what we buy how we vote
even how we think news voice is created
by its readers as you can upvote stories
that you find interesting so more people
will see them it's essentially a
democratized platform for the news plus
it saves you time you get all the news
and all the sources in one app so that
you can stay better informed and it's
also totally free anyway get started
with news voice today for free through
the link below it's available on both
Google Play and the App Store and let's
get into it
[Applause]
[Music]
our country is in the midst of a great
national trial unlike any we have ever
faced before know some I'm gay I'm gay
senator theft I developed mild symptoms
old the greater virus I've taken a test
Shimon Avidan IBM Oh super out that's
big losses in me sorry yes wimzie's oh
and todos los trabajadores de barajas no
I am fearless de barranca Darcy in Gaza
in las próximas
dos semanas we've all seen the pictures
online of people who seem to think
they're invincible
well you're not enough is enough go home
and stay home
country after country this spread of
covert 19 is paralyzing an enormous part
of the world's economy to curb the
spread of the virus states are decreeing
all kinds of extraordinary measures
including the confinement of entire
populations in their homes border
closures and the suspension of most
commercial and industrial activity
obviously this whole situation is gonna
have economic consequences huge ones
consequences that can even reach
professional sport monitors staff is
reduced FC barcelona's squad confirmed
on Monday that they have accepted a 70%
paid cut while the state of emergency
continues due to coronavirus you rope a
press wait are we gonna met a picture we
start to see headlines like this
economic shutdown and confinement leave
240,000 companies on the brink of
bankruptcy four out of ten Spanish
companies are making losses they're the
most vulnerable if the freeze on the
country's production system is prolonged
the confidence yeah
the problem with pressing this kind of a
nuclear button suddenly paralyzes the
economic and social activity of an
entire country is not only does it
translate into the immediate damage that
comes with having companies closed down
completely but we also do not have the
remotest idea how long it's going to
take us to recover not what the final
consequences are going to be once we've
defeated the virus
[Music]
and let's not fool ourselves governments
need to be cautious and they won't lift
the extraordinary measures they have
taken all at once instead they will do
so little by little to avoid a second
wave of infection and the safest way
maybe for some restrictions to be kept
in place until a vaccine or effective
treatment is found this is exactly
what's happening now in Asian countries
that seem to have covert 19-under
control many of the restrictions
affecting public places such as cinemas
restaurants hotels and shopping centers
will remain in place and that's not all
in China they're restricting entry to
the country and canceling most
international flights in Taiwan
quarantine for people returning to the
country is mandatory and ignoring it
means fines of up to $30,000 access for
non-residents as in Hong Kong and
Singapore has been virtually vetoed for
their part in South Korea foreigners can
enter but they must comply with a
quarantine of 14 days in an apartment or
hotel room well everything indicates
that we will also see these kinds of
measures later throughout the rest of
the world
in other words economic damage could
drag on for quite a long time on the
other hand many industries the damage is
already done and returning to normality
will require a titanic effort the
tourism sector needs on average about
nineteen point four months to recover
from epidemics more so than the eleven
point five months needed to recover from
terrorist attacks a digit koala fidelity
fund manager and of course the
government's themselves I'm going to get
away scot-free either if there's one
thing we've learned over the last few
decades it's that economic crises often
results in huge gigantic mountains of
public debt and this time it's not gonna
be any different many countries will
register such large budget deficits
throughout 2020 that this in itself
could lead to a new financial crisis and
that's why we get news stories like this
one
the ECB pulls out its bazooka and breaks
all asset purchase records in a week The
Economist to give you an idea the
european central bank has prepared all
the heavy artillery it has to prevent
risk premiums from countries like Spain
or Italy from storing into the
stratosphere you see in order to deal
with this crisis and make it easier for
European governments to borrow at
reduced rates the European Central Bank
has launched a program to buy public and
private debt with a budget of 750
billion euros in the week of the 23rd of
March 20 2011 central bank bought assets
about 39 billion euros more than 48
billion dollars this is the highest
weekly level of debt purchased in its
entire history in other words despite
all the discussion of bailouts in Italy
or Spain the truth is that the European
Central Bank is already rescuing the
European countries most affected by the
crisis now wait a second clearly the
crisis is not limited to the old
continents in fact at the time of making
this video the country with the most
coronavirus infections on the planet was
none other than the United States
[Music]
and this brings up some questions what
are the consequences of the spread of
the virus and how does the United States
plan to deal with the looming crisis did
you know that the United States just
launched the biggest rescue program in
history or listen up real slap in the
face
[Music]
in a past video here on visual politic
we told you how for weeks the government
of Spain completely ignored the
existence of coronavirus and this went
on until of course it was too late to
stop the spread well something very very
similar happened in the United States
and of course when events evolved it did
not have all very differently with more
than 500,000 infected the United States
has the highest number of cases
worldwide and the highest growth rate
and what all Americans to be prepared
for difficult days ahead we're going to
go through a tough few weeks Donald
Trump to give you an idea an imperial
college report has determined that if no
measures had been taken coronavirus
would have ended the lives of more than
two million Americans
even now after measures such as
confinement travel restrictions and the
closure of schools universities and
workplaces have been put in place the
White House's leading scientific
advisors estimates that this pathogen is
at best going to end the lives of more
than a hundred thousand Americans of
course the economic consequences are
already beginning to be felt at the
beginning of March it took 15 days for
u.s. stock exchanges to record the
quickest crash in their entire history
it's just over 15 days the sp500 the
index that brings together the 500
largest list of companies in the United
States fell more than 30 percent from
its highest levels financial firms such
as Goldman Sachs JP Morgan and Morgan
Stanley expects the US economy to fall
into recession and recorded GDP Falls
Morgan Stanley for example expects the
US economy to shrink in the second
quarter of the year between 24 and 30
percent of GDP compared to the same
quarter in 2019 these are figures that
have never been seen before
and for the moment unemployment data is
not exactly optimistic over 10 million
Americans applied for unemployment
benefits in March as the economy
collapsed a record six point six five
million people filed new jobless claims
in the week that ended March 28
Washington Post 10 million people in a
single month we are talking about a job
destruction figure that is unprecedented
largely because the economy has never
stopped in such a way before
all this also comes at a time when many
companies have taken on a loss of debt
in recent years thanks to low interest
rates to such an extent that in the
United States corporate debt is at its
highest level in the last 40 years and
obviously one of the risks that exists
if the health crisis lasts too long is
that many companies are gonna see their
turnover fall sharply they're going to
show losses and then many might have
trouble repaying all of those
outstanding debts
it stands to reason that the damage will
be greater the longer it takes to
overcome this health crisis but the
truth is we don't know how long it will
take or how the recovery will look
whether it will come in the form of a V
U or W shape on a graph nobody you can
say what we do know from earlier
precedence is that the risk of permanent
damage is high for example it is known
that during the so-called Spanish flu
outbreak which killed more than 500,000
Americans the hardest hit areas
experienced a relative decline in
employment industrial production and
Bank assets over the subsequent few
years then we have the case of major
natural disasters like Hurricane Katrina
which is obviously not an epidemic that
was an external shock that caused
similar effects to some extent well
after the impacts of Katrina the lack of
initial reaction caused employment to
collapse by more than 30 percent and two
years after the event barely half of the
decline in economic activity had been
recovered
[Music]
the fact is that during the month of
March 2020 all economic indicators have
begun to fall strongly in the United
States consumption investment exports as
has happened in Europe the economy is
shutting down to try and contain the
coronavirus crisis and mitigate its
effects the question now is how do we
avoid a big economic crisis or rather
how can we overcome this bump without
excessively grave economic damage I'll
take a look at this I think this is the
part that we really need to take
personal responsibility for Saturday the
mother of all bailouts offer a quick and
near unanimous agreements between
Republicans and Democrats both in the
Senate and in the House of
Representatives Donald Trump signs the
law that will ensure the biggest bailout
in US history on March the 28th 2.2
trillion dollars 10 percent of GDP in
order to cope with the economic
consequences of the coronavirus no
economic policy can fully end the
hardship this isn't even a stimulus
package it is emergency relief it is
emergency relief that's what this is
Mitch McConnell Senate Majority Leader
for today I'll sign the single biggest
economic relief package in American
history and I must say or any other
package by the way it's twice as large
as any relief ever signed it's 2.2
million but it actually goes up to 6
point to potentially billion dollars
trillion dollars now I know what many of
you are wondering but Simon what exactly
is this huge amount of money going
towards well let's break it down
first over 300 billion dollars is going
to be spent sending checks to the vast
majority of US citizens yep paper checks
specifically every person who earns less
than 75 thousand dollars a year is going
to receive a check for $1,200 and $500
per child in this way a family of four
that earns less than a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year will receive
checks worth three thousand four hundred
dollars to compensate for the damage
caused by the crisis if they earn more
the amount is progressively reduced and
just over 200 billion dollars goes
towards extending the right to
unemployment insurance the number of
people who can apply for is the time
during which can be obtained and also
the number of payments to be received
over the next four months has been
increased and take note of this one the
bailout also suggests that insurers will
have to bear the costs of this disease
the fundamental idea is that families do
not cut their consumption levels even if
it's at the expense of the public budget
6.2 trillion dollars I've never signed
anything with the tea on it we can't
check it out at this point for small and
medium-sized businesses a 360 billion
dollar line in equity loans has opened
up that is concessional held loans that
can be partially canceled if certain
requirements such as maintaining the
number of employees and payments to
suppliers are met for large companies
this amount increases to 500 billion
dollars however in this case large
corporations will have to meet some
requirements such as suspending share
buyback programs and the process will be
closely evaluated by a monitoring
committee
finally the plan includes more than a
hundred and twenty five billion dollars
fast bottles drugs and medical
equipments and three hundred and thirty
nine billion dollars to support the
fight against coronavirus at the state
and municipal government level these are
the main measures of the largest rescue
package in US history the plan with
which the Trump administration hopes to
mitigate the damage caused by
coronavirus
that's the biggest problem with this
package is that the United States has
entered this crisis without doing its
homework so let me explain the Trump
administration had projected a public
deficit of just over a trillion dollars
for this year 2020 that is almost five
percent of GDP a gigantic hole
especially considering that the US
economy has been growing for more than
ten years well the thing is now that
with this rescue package and the damage
that the crisis could cause the public
coffers the deficit is going to
skyrocket so levels not seen since World
War two levels that could be between 15
and 20 percent of GDP to give you an
idea Morgan Stanley's recent estimates
suggest that during 2020 and 2021 the US
government's public deficit will amounts
to nearly five trillion dollars
virtually the size of Japan's entire
economy which is the third largest
economy on the planet after the United
States and China
in other words the u.s. national debt
could exceed a hundred and twenty-five
percent in just two years the question
is how is it gonna be financed well the
Federal Reserve is gonna play a key role
it's already announced that it's gonna
buy government bonds like there's no
tomorrow and that that's what explains
why headlines like this start to appear
coronavirus sparks US dollar dilemma for
China's Federal Reserve ramps up easing
china is the world's second largest
holder of US government debt with about
1.1 trillion US dollars worth of US
Treasury bonds and its foreign reserves
as the US Federal Reserve scales up
monetary easing pushing down bond yields
some analysts have asked whether Beijing
should sell its US Treasury holdings
SCMP so are we facing a turning point in
global geopolitics could coronavirus
mean a new transfer of influence from
the west to the east will trumps plan to
rescue the US economy actually work
these are some of the key questions that
need answers and let us know what you
think in the comments below and I really
do hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit like if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check out our friends at
reconsider media they provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]